okay we are talking about things do with
dates I am a bit subdued because I have
a cold today but we will see what we can
do okay we are talking first about date
interval those are a few choice rough
Beach frightened these examples will
also evaluate in prototype builds if you
have one okay oh great Mia starter
prototype build
that's really weird look at that
striation of that button
yeah this little rendering artifact
Allah say Oh God this era here the
specified font color error that's been
there for like three months
do I need to who's peering here okay can
you go kick the front-end team and just
say get rid of this this message what is
it yes there for like three months
yep should be able to get rid of it okay
um background noise somebody should
you
you
this is one of the two objects we are
working on the other one being the array
de touraine okay what is beta ray so
that would be a collection of data
objects a bit like the relation between
quantity on quantity right it's not
there yet so we are reviewing only but
it just to to to show the fact that
there is a difference between those two
okay so this could be a multi interval
where this thing here right following
interval itself right
oh please don't do that please don't
ever do that don't do that just list
them here as well okay
suppose the final instance
and the clarity so the start and end
dates can have their own granularities
right so they can ever own granularities
as input but the the date interval
itself has a canonical granularity it's
either you know all instance between
those endpoints or it can be
canonicalized as all days between them
but you can have a start point that is
an instant and an end point that's a day
and we basically canonicalize those two
the representation of the intervals
granularity but but you've got to do
something by default it's got one
argument right what do you do by default
in that case if it's got one argument
that's a granular date you've got one
argument the start is an instant the end
is a day what do you do
so our default behavior is that if you
don't specify a granularity otherwise we
say the granularity of the interval is
instant it's all instance between those
points I don't think that's right I
don't think it's right if you've got
listen if you've gotten too granular to
start and end or both days right I don't
think you want the instant from midnight
to midnight of those days do you so
right now we have many functions in the
system that takes like specification of
one day to another date and they
interpret all of those as instants so
our thinking was what are those
functions going to do if suddenly they
we force them to say what's an example
of such a function yeah I mean any of
the data lookup functions have what so
weather data financial data the energy
value functions use a date a start date
and end date and are inclusive of all
points between there you can also
explicitly
they specify a step size for sampling
but there are that's kind of wrong yeah
I mean it is it's yeah there's a
difference between what a date interval
represents an explicit date range
specification but they're closely
related
yeah but date range with the step means
sample it at many possible steps right
so the granularity of data interval
you're saying represents the the
collection of days between those two
start and end points is that right yes
it's the granularity of the dates
contained in that interval so if even so
so for example let's say I say date
interval of ah you know now - three
weeks
- now granularity of days okay now how
do I get the explicit days within those
times how do I break the data interval
into its granular pieces so if you so
there's a property right now of that
data interval that if you said percent
Open bracket
dates it would give you how would know
that's not what I want I want the actual
granular days the list of days with date
range range of these should and duration
a percent one what the hell is that well
that obviously should work right yeah
that's a hookup we haven't done right
now there is a property for duration I
can see that that's not good enough
um I am not at all convinced about this
thing I'm sorry and so you're saying
date range which normally guts as input
date one day to an increment right hmm
so if I say this what the hell is that
oh I see now - so that's the instant
there but I understand oh that's the
step but what about the granularity so
for date range the granularity is
determined by the start date so if you
say date object
days yeah okay okay in principle a date
range could just consume a deep interval
object that would have to start and end
and granularity by default we've all do
what default I mean if the granularity
by default is instant then obviously it
can't evaluate right yeah I mean that's
the so the tricky thing about having a
granularity and the date intervals is
that we don't necessarily want the
behavior of the granularity to be super
strict in terms of we don't want to date
interval that has a granularity of days
to reject comparisons with other
granular objects because it just
wouldn't be very useful so in some ways
the granularity is a sort of abstract
and playing rate or a meta information
about the range because it ultimately
can boil down to
there's a very why didn't that work the
comparisons were broken recently there
because I was tweaking some things but
it would absolutely work normally good
okay there it works with date overlaps Q
and day within Q and interval operations
right now also but there are ambiguity
problems with if you said is that
interval less than 4
for example we worked with mark or with
Rob some time ago about getting interval
comparisons to handle those cases
well it won't evaluate right yeah it
wouldn't evaluate in the same way that
if you said is today less than now we
would not we don't evaluate it and we
give a warning message that says you're
comparing dates of unequal granularity
and the result is indeterminate it
shouldn't be typesetting that way a bit
oh well that's good this stuff is
horrible yeah um yeah we definitely
don't want all this crap there mm-hmm
somebody's asking freaking to display
dates us and one clocks I think we can
call me if you feed one of these date
objects into a one of our clock things
that not correct
yokka gauge gauge
amazing I didn't actually know that
worked mm-hmm that's cool we should put
that example on the on the certainly in
properties and relations on the date
indeed oh yeah that's actually really
cool um okay all right so let's look
back here what is this I don't
understand this I just don't understand
this just seems wrong to me if you have
a date interval look it should be August
31st inclusive which means going to you
know the instant before midnight on the
next day
shouldn't it I don't understand yes
wrong
that's the question they're about in
terms of if you're specifying date list
do we handle them in the same way the
data object does where we infer the
granularity based on the length of them
and for the left hand side we good the
first moment and the right hand side we
go to the last moment which is it sounds
like what you wanted I think so but I
mean how do we get to that last moment
right now what's the function that does
that okay go ahead
yeah with so right now we don't have a
exposed system function it's one of the
items that's farther down is if we
should have a last date function or a
date and argument and date bounds that
lets you extract the last moment or the
last object of a given granularity from
an existing date I think we should
whether it's I think it's a slightly
obscure thing so um yeah so date bounds
currently doesn't do sub sampling from
within granular objects so you can give
it a list of dates or it will get bounds
out of
containers like time-series or data bins
I see so if you gave it a single object
a single granular object then in
principle I mean here you could give it
a granularity who'd give date bounds of
granularity and ask it now I don't quite
understand what the instant that is
right before midnight is right there's
an opening closed right hand side
problem when it comes to instance of how
we want to handle you know what is the
last included instant of the day so in
the case of interval max of an interval
is the right-hand end of the interval
right right the problem is I mean it's
basically midnight minus epsilon and
that's hard to specify yeah okay well
let's keep going here
yeah I think the state interval form is
okay III think this is kind of not you
know these data intervals are
complicated I don't think we should try
to do this okay yeah I think that
generally makes sense
you
you
well as it's a calendar the calendar
granulite it's a granularity yeah we can
sure we've generally been referring to
cat calendar great doesn't it isn't as
pertinent for our but because the
granularity of the date is inherently
tied to the calendar type when we refer
to granularity for clarity's sake we
often try to reference calendar
granularity altitude was completely
crazy for our yeah I think for our
minute and seconds it isn't relevant
yeah it can probably be shortened there
just as granularity
meaning is less obvious through so
through in this case four days means
you're gonna get to the end of that day
right right so Monday through Friday
includes Friday but Jose and I have sort
of gone back and forth on this I feel
like it's the until meaning it stops at
11:00 p.m. or does the until mean it
goes through the hour of 11:00 p.m. yes
so the object that you're looking at
right now says through and that means it
goes through the end of 11:00 p.m. if we
were to say until 11 p.m. my general
interpretation of that would be that it
stops at 11:00 if your business hours
are 9:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
you can't show up at 5:30 and expect to
come in but I generally don't really
hear a lot of common usage of when
you're talking about fine granularity of
our minute second of someone saying
through yeah no I agree I mean it
wouldn't be through 11:00 p.m. it would
be through the 11th hour so to speak
mm-hmm is that for hours and minutes and
even seconds we should show the last
instant even if it is going right the
hour so sir how can we show the
Larsson's I mean : 50 now I know what
from from 17th 1200 to 18th 1200 yeah
and if you say from midnight to midnight
yeah and I think if we did that we would
probably change the label from through
to until just to make that pretty clear
yes
you mean the display yeah yeah there's
way of it but in the internal form what
would it be would it go to the 11:00
p.m. and the internal form or would it
go to so our our current version of the
internal form says for non instant cases
because instance its own hairy problem
both endpoints are included and they go
out to their full bounds
so the input form right below that goes
to 11:00 p.m. and the internal code
knows that because that is an hour
granular object that includes all things
that happen within 11:00 p.m. so when I
live stream is all soaking where the
data objects can be read faster yes that
is a big effort hmm that's part of this
project is to me I'm faster
yeah we've been migrating and optimizing
code as part of this but that's a
general umbrella project to streamline
things and to generalize the handling of
things like time zones and calendars
also and it's also the object that will
handle many data objects yes which will
be a big help for temporal data some one
truth on the live stream was was
complaints didn't work in the cloud I'm
not surprised doesn't work in the cloud
I think the cloud refuses to let itself
be interrupted that quickly and that
does seem to work here I don't know what
the one is
well who knows what that one has been
made that seems to work um okay so back
to this
well I mean so I guess my my general
question would be is it confusing to
have the language switch between through
and until handling the end points it and
if so should we just have everything
always be implicitly open on the right
so the full form is always showing the
first no that's gonna be super confusing
I mean I think the print form I mean the
thing that is confusing here is that the
print form is going to display a
different date than what is there
internally right so so if we say the
min/max
so in the case of a up to midnight okay
so if I say this okay so now I say that
thing max okay now I'm totally confused
it's so that's the granular hour because
the data intervals in our green then the
only way you're gonna do this is to say
12 11 p.m. to midnight for that granular
hour mmm I mean if what we did for a
granular hour was to display that as
11:00 p.m. to midnight I think we'll be
okay okay yeah in other words the hour
is a weird case because a minute you
know right you wouldn't really say from
fire from 11 o 6 to 11 I was 7
no you wouldn't pretty clear I'd love
you to say you know so let's look at
these other ones okay so for a day you
wouldn't do that either we understand
days a day means the whole day inclusive
right the problem is that for whatever
reason of human experience or something
our doesn't work that way so that a
granular hour really needs to be 11 p.m.
to midnight
that makes sense yeah so if we did that
if the general print form of a granular
hour contained that I think we will be
good shape over here as well right it's
sort of like the typeset form for our
centuries we'll show the story later
date so if you said current date century
a sense of mm that's crazy what's that
oh I was just saying for a date object
itself but yeah that okay women but so
you're saying current date of century
it's sort of the general version of it
but if yeah that's a weird case right
because minutes it's the we really
decided to put the apostrophe there yeah
that's what we went with to to clarify
that it was the 2000s and not just
referring to the year 2000 no I
understand but the question is whether
the apostrophe should be there whether
it should just be an S at the end did we
asked dqa about that
I don't recall us and we can just let's
let's check that it looks probably wrong
to me but we may have decided this
because of self-consistency that's
another case I mean both things are used
in the world I just think this one
doesn't make a lot of sense because in
English that tends to be a possessive
form which certainly isn't okay but
anyway it's about backing up to the
hours idea so we're saying a granular
hour becomes something which is
displayed as 12
you know usually it will be 1 to 2 p.m.
but sometimes if it goes across the
am/pm marker then it has to say it
differently right yeah um I actually
like that are there any other ones we
have to worry about that with seconds
and minutes you don't have to really
worry we've always ended up having their
custom typesetting for
just because well every week you have to
say bless you right mm-hmm
what do we do for week so right now we
say week beginning so if you did current
day week say week beginning Monday we
don't type set it as Monday through
Sunday and if you do week beginning
Sunday well I mean we could obviously do
the same thing for our we could say our
beginning but I think it's more obscure
yeah I mean our beginning would
certainly make it you know actually do
the right thing mm-hmm that to avoid
confusion with interval from two may
suggest this is enough yeah I mean I
think granular hours is a weird thing
anyway and I think this is a reasonable
way to handle it fine so if we do that
then how would we represent this because
this is now saying that's an hour
granularity but it doesn't explicitly
say our granularity mm-hmm I mean we end
up with beginning beginning of that hour
beginning of our beginning this to the
first line shorter lines so in the same
way that for grammar at 8 objects we do
show always second relative we are for
date intervals and then can write the
hour from two and different men to our
two instance possibly or we could have
the granularity be part of the label so
our beginning instant beginning year
beginning
let's find I don't think we need to say
instant beginning I think we just say
beginning yeah um
Bob on the live stream is asking about
Chinese yes we have those don't we we
don't have the the Chinese calendar
integrated there there are some
complications with the way that the
cycles are built into the the Chinese
calendar we have a prototype version
that we have and we have some internal
versions used for like holiday calendars
but there's a larger calendar project to
expand what we have that includes some
core functionality and some things that
may be part of summer intern projects
just to flesh out you know the adding
support for the Mayan calendar isn't a
super high computational priority but
it's something that's pretty modular
that could be done by certain things
yeah okay be nice to have probably a lot
of yeah the Mayan market is modest yeah
and some like the Japanese calendar
don't have real good canonical forms
like there plenty of internal ways to
represent eight represent it but having
IRA's as sort of a string precursor to a
date list is a little weird so some of
those requires some design and some of
them are okay all right okay
by the way sort of the lifestream is all
skids it related is this related
temporal logic yeah it is related its
temporal object but I don't know what's
happened to our temporal logic project
what has happened to that so Jiang was
working on that but since Christmas he
came very busy with his studies and then
some family issues doing the same as
well so but he wants to come back as
soon as he can okay but do we have a
design that wasn't crazy for that well
what we learned in the last meeting we
had with you is that you had a larger
idea what temporal logic is so we were
focusing on what is usually called
temporal logic which is the model logic
applied to to to time really and that
for that we had a design using the
standard words like until setter and
what was my generalization of that I
mean I wanted it to be concrete as well
as be symbolic yeah yes but I think you
had an interpretation of temporal logic
that included not only the logic part
but also the interaction with date
intervals and other thing
so so we presented you was pure a pure
extension of boolean logic with just a
few more operators yes I see I see but
we need to concrete fi that by actually
being able to say until an annotation to
Malone things exactly yes that was the
part we will explore in the literature
and indeed there are extensions to
include these things but but we didn't
have that yet okay fair enough okay what
am I looking at here is this so just a
basic overview that the same sort of
arithmetic operations that work on dates
work on data intervals as well and we
handle interval results in quantities as
quantities with interval values say that
again what and yeah I mean basically if
you are taking the difference of a date
interval to either another data interval
or to a specific date the result is a
quantity with an interval magnitude I
see because
date because it's a difference like with
degrees like with temperatures mmm it's
no longer a date it is a quantity right
yeah okay makes sense so I assume that I
can put dates into an interval and it
will turn itself into a date interval
yeah that's I don't have that fully
hooked up right now because there are a
couple of Fringe bits of functionality
that use that notation for something
else but the intention is that interval
of data objects will canonicalize to a
date interval and so things like I
hooked up an interface with time line
plot for example so it understands data
intervals wonderful do we have it
designed for what the actual timeline
looks like that what do we already have
that yeah we already have that so like
you know we basically have our our two
endpoints and a line running between
them okay fine
how is that represented in the input to
table head plot right now so time line
plot does support a interval of two data
objects to represent that fine fine okay
so I don't think we need data interval
queue let them read the head yeah my
field
should probably let itself be given as a
blob of the first two arguments mm-hmm
yeah and our general paradigm is that
any function that needs to reduce a
either a granular date or a date
interval or something that's sort of an
extended period of time to a specific
moment the canonical way we do that is
we take the first moment so if you say
date list of a date interval we can't
really give that so you're proposing
that we have first date on lost date
yeah and it would be it would be
particularly useful for data interval
but it could be generalized to work on
granular data objects or from you know
as a convenience on time series or data
bin and having it I mean one thing that
I don't like is the word date as opposed
to time here mm-hmm but I mean we've
kind of you know with dateless plot I
mean it's kind of ugly because some
things are thought of as x some things
are thought of as dates yeah I mean
dates are more common but because we
also have time objects I think we are
trying to move away from from time to
date and cause here they does this more
general object oh I understand that we
could say mean date max date yes
I think that makes more sense because
min and Max do a does min apply to a
date interval yeah it does right now
said in the same way that it works on an
interval so why don't we just use min
why why we introduced a new function for
this I think the main thing would be if
we want to specify a granularity to
extract we could just add that
functionality to date bounds and then
you just say first or last of date
bounds but well wait the granularity the
you extract if I if I want to change
this I can always say date object of
that comma minute
can't I right yeah you can and that will
change it but the there's a difference
between taking so if I have a date
interval that represents this month and
I say I want the maximum value from it
and it is I understand what you're
saying the maximum value the maximum day
is the last day of the month right if I
then say hour it will go to the first
hour of that resulting data objects but
as opposed to yeah yeah so it it may be
a bit of an edge case but there's some
case for we have internal tools that do
that sort of I think it makes sense max
date min date make some sense with a
granularity and having granularity for
date bounds makes perfect sense to me
okay so that's saying within that date
interval give me the first hour in the
last hour within that date interval
correct okay sounds good to me
all right now we go into null infinities
and all this kind of stuff we just wait
until we actually have proper general
Authority implemented in this yeah it
was giving me a hard time about what
what nature of infinite future and
infinite past are we talking about
um okay what is this for
so we initially had looked at the idea
of infinite future infinite past is
being useful in a date interval saying
you know yeah forever forever now I'm
now in Hanceville yeah and when looking
at hooking that up I thought it would be
potentially useful to have infinite
dates as standalone results so we could
have a data object that represents the
infinite future
I don't see why not I mean that seems
like a useful thing because if you want
to say from I mean I'm thinking of
computational contracts right from here
on forwards until the end of time right
um and initially when I was looking at
them in in date interval I had imagined
infinite future infinite past would just
be inert symbols but having them be a
canonical form of date notation where
you have a date object that has a first
argument that is infinity means that we
can expand that to work in the larger
date framework we could have absolute
time give a directed infinity value and
what's the alternative thing so that's
the granularity because we didn't really
want the notion to have date object of
infinity comma instance there isn't
really a granularity associated with an
infinite future infinite past and it
also helps distinguish the form of it
you know it's essentially the largest
possible granularity you have let's
let's do a little physics discussion
here okay remind me how they how this
works I mean the notion of of infinite
future infinite past in the generosity
setting all these script whatever they
are you know future null infinity past
null infinity all these kinds of things
yes it's a bit like our directed
infinity the fact that because we are
not
4-dimensional but we can think of two
dimensional space in time and space and
then if we say the light rays move
always in in 45 degrees so do they go to
the infinity which is directed
vertically in the time direction or the
space direction and then it was invented
that they go to daily special infinity
which is not infinity because for zero
mass particle there's no passage of time
yes that's a consequence but more
importantly is that I mean this is done
through what is called the conformal
transformation right in which they try
to bring infinity at a finite distance
and when you do that you end up with
this type of diamund in which you have
infinity at the top my past infinity and
then you have the spatial infinities on
the sides and the and the and the lines
between those mm points of the diamond
are null infinities which which are the
places where the light rays go right but
the light rays have this weird feature
that they don't have any notion of the
passage of time correct yes yes okay so
let's understand that for our purposes
here okay so I'm just thinking gosh I
think that this is our description of
the time axis the vertical axis so for
us these these infinities are the time
infinities the future infinity and them
okay but you know what when we do
spatial logic we're gonna want a spatial
infinity as well yes yes I so this would
be like the same way that we have
infinity and directed infinity and
complex infinity etcetera hmm if we
happen to be at some point doing these
various things we will need a way of
distinguishing these possibilities right
Peter
in particular array versus a finite line
segment right what what is the what is
the end point of array no we don't we
already have that in the computational
geometry stuff where you can have an
infinite coordinate in array mmm we have
these infinite lines right like a half
line right and if half spaces in school
so so that gives a vector this is twelve
point one getting itself confused what
is going on here okay represents a half
line okay in that direction so in the
spatial case of this
yeah okay so in the time version of this
there is a notion of a half line which
is what you're giving here from from now
until infinite future right that would
be an example of a one dimensional half
line effectively in the time direction
and I guess my question is I mean is the
right thing to have an infinite future
or is it to have which we which is not
what we do in the spatial case because
in the special case apart from Direction
infinite we don't have a way to say
we're in space right and in the time
case because one-dimensional right we
only have to worry about you know
there's a well-defined plus infinity and
minus infinity right and then the
complex is space with an angle which is
what we do with direct at infinity it's
enough
yes I understand but so my question here
is is what we want actually infinite
future or is it an interval from now
until the infinite future for is that
best represented it's just a data
interval from nano comma infinite future
right I would separate the point
infinite future an different price from
the interval which goes from some point
to infinite future
okay so fine so what you're saying is
like now to infinite future exactly okay
so what the heck is this thing
can the grill out is instant so that's
that's a collection of instance from now
to the infinite future okay so if I say
the max of us what Nick has on their
left side doesn't yeah so that shouldn't
appear obviously yeah I think it's
important to distinguish the actual data
object of infinite future from intervals
that go from somewhere to infinite
future 19 duration I want to know what
that is
yeah yeah it's not fully integrated at
this point but so what should it be
should it be an infinite quantity do we
have internal quantities do they work
okay so if I say quantity infinity
seconds for example okay if I say 1 over
that apart from the weird spacing which
is definitely wrong where it should be
fixed yeah okay okay so we do have
infinite quantities all right so the
only question that is with the duration
here um I would say if there was a
generality originally we keep it if not
we say seconds
which is the fundamental unit of time
yeah I mean look if this is being used
for human purposes years is gonna be
more relevant as in if one's writing you
know this you know let's say I was
writing a contract once says um you know
on such-and-such a date the I don't know
somebody's some kinda why I'm thinking
something silly like somebody has you
know given a donation to a university on
the condition that on October 10th every
year they they put up some weird thing
in the quad or something who knows but
that that contract basically says from
now you know for an infinite number of
years I I don't know it seems more
natural one second second seems more
scientific but I can't imagine this is
going to be used that the infinite
future is going to be used for
scientific purposes here okay um it's
true that we when we have only the
infinity as we see on the left hand side
we put infinity in the years because
it's it's the shortest representation
sorry well where is that yes on the left
hand side you see that infinity infinity
past is represented as a as a single
list I see I see I see in which means
it's in the year element of the list
structure exactly okay so let's talk
about the granularity of eternity why
because we have larger it sounded it has
to be dears at least because we put it
there it's not what does it mean that
the granularity is eternity what does
that mean when you doesn't that mean
that it eats anything else that the
Eternity granularity is just like yes so
how does that work yes we do arithmetic
with different granularities
the biggest
wine wings and so because this is going
to be bigger than anyone well that makes
sense otherwise you get goofy things
with infinity plus seven years I see so
that's basically saying okay what's the
answer - okay so infinite past infinite
future - infinite past should give okay
it's in our own right now but it should
give what should that give that should
just give an infinite number of seconds
in an infinite number of years exactly
what bothers me here is I could imagine
see here this could be almost read as an
infinite number of eternities I
explained to me why that doesn't mean oh
I see it's a granularity that's where
the starting point is is an eternity
away it's starting point it's not it's
not growing arised two years for example
I think it makes sense yeah because the
first argument again is still sort of
the year argument of the date list you
know when we have when you have data
object with a granularity of century we
don't change the date list
representation - suddenly the first
argument means century is it's still
years but it gets abstracted out to be a
century sort of a expanded granularity
in the calendar all right let me just
ask a couple of questions here about the
physics case so when we start doing
stuff in a stroke coordinates okay where
we have to have [ __ ] coordinate
systems and all kinds of weird things
like that
how will this effect how will this be
affected here I mean so in other words
the the position of Jupiter or something
is how will that work what would we do
there no I mean in general I'm just
trying to understand because then I'm
going to talk about infinity in a minute
I'm just trying to understand what is
mean because clearly the simultaneous
right you know I'm talking about but we
have to have the state of the solar
system for example at a given point is
unmeasurable right though they they
[ __ ] positions are immeasurable
right
so the key thing there will be a concept
that we don't yet have which is the time
system so together with a calendar some
sort of the coordinate we will need
something called time system and there
we will have things like solar time
atomic time UTC time measure from the
center of the solar system time measure
from the surface of the earth time
measure from the body center of the
earth and so that then will be [ __ ]
time so that is a time system there's
also a location and exactly so this will
specify the method you are using to
measure time I understand although
typically that would be a light signal
from whatever wherever the center of the
wherever you say it's measured with
respect to that true well here we have
to be very careful with the measure of
time and the measure of durations of
some process which will be quantities
okay so some things here will be again
data specifications in which at I see a
time system will specify exactly how you
measured it and and other in other cases
we will be dealing with quantities so
wait a minute let's be practical okay so
the what is I don't know what what's the
time to light first signal getting to
Mars like 20 minutes or something the
moon it's like couple of seconds so now
the question is um we say the spacecraft
landed at such-and-such a time right
right and so that is with respect to a
time system we can give that as a time
system centered on Earth
in which case the actual time on a clock
on Mars will be 20 minutes earlier or
something not true right and there we
will have to be very careful because for
example something imagine a space rocket
which is at the same position of the
earth but moving in a different
direction then it will it will not have
the same time as the earth so so
positions is not the only thing that
matters here velocities also matter what
about accelerations as well I mean there
was it is the fundamental thing okay we
can we can say that we have to measure
the velocity but yes acceleration also
please don't wait a minute how does that
work so I mean if you measure the
instantaneous velocity have some
relativistic time dilation some gamma
but the gravitational field this is a
mess my god
it's complicated but the important thing
is that the information can be all
placed in the time system so remember
this is a bit like India we have the
projections and the datums the
projections are the coordinates the
datums
are the specification of how we measure
things so here we have the equivalence
of the calendars like the projections
and the time systems like the items
explain that to me again so datums give
you I mean like like a particular datum
tells you like how high you are and also
to the nominal surface aveer well they
do is for example a reference system
like ad like the three axis from which
you are going to measure things yes
right and you have to give experimental
method to say how you are fixing those
three axis once you have these three
axis you can start saying now I'm going
to use spherical coordinates or
cylindrical coordinates or Cartesian
coordinates I think I understand
although I think it's a little bit more
complicated right when you have a given
that you're explaining that not only do
you need to know I see you that the time
system is actually a spacetime system is
it not right right so this time
needs to have specification that's right
you have to say it's something like what
this atomic time atomic time will say we
are measuring time with atomic clocks
situated at the surface of the earth
from this exact date and then that's a
continuous counting of seconds you know
leap seconds for anything there and and
the rate of those seconds country will
be affected by gravitational redshift
and things well for each clock the rate
of seconds is exactly the same one but
of course if you place those clock in
different places when you compare them
right on the surface of the earth versus
in you know away from the gravity of the
earth they'll be a different rate yes
what I'm saying is that the the physical
atomic clock works in the very same way
everywhere when you compare them one has
been floating in space and then comes
back to earth then it's when deuce mm
can appreciate the difference all right
is this relevant to what we're talking
about here when we introduce time system
which I know I'm a little worried about
the interaction between time system and
infinite future that's I guess what I'm
what I'm poking out because time system
you see this is going to get into this
null infinity nonsense because what's
gonna happen is infinite future so I'm
saying in for a future here I'm confused
well our infinities here are the time
infinities if you ever need the null
infinities we will have to introduce new
concepts for for them
you know okay so it's the same thing as
our infinity and complex infinity right
so right they are different concepts and
they have different and then at the end
they all go to directed infinity various
comments on a live stream and then we
should wrap it up here yeah mathematical
musings are saying this is like this is
about Penrose diagram
yes that's what those come for
transformed things are for infinities in
3d space would you need a direction -
yes okay okay
senator is saying date difference of
date 1 comma infinite future could have
the same units of the granularity of
date 1 it could they be equivalent since
it's an infinite value of time units no
I understand it that's what we've been
discussing as well the quantity that's
not unreasonable because that at least
gives you the opportunity which there's
no granularity flow you're not wrong
we're gonna have eternity that we use
years fine
if it's in for a positive in future then
we have to use years yep yes um
commenting this is like a philosophy
channel yeah well the thing that's
always fun with this stuff is in order
to actually get the stuff right you have
to go pretty far help there sometimes
and philosophy physics whatever um let's
see okay um as Thomas H is saying
space-time event as a way to wrap to
your position and date object together
yes what is our way of doing that we
have a because we have that for these
some lists or for arguments then they
are spaced fence
and and you can extract the data object
from there I understand yeah I mean it
has an absolute time specification as
its as its fourth element I mean I agree
that once we get into you know stuff in
the solar system and so on I suspect
we're gonna end up with things more like
space-time events because geo position
is a very bizarre um well it may not
mean yeah the plan is to have an astral
position which takes care of coordinate
systems and and and these frame
specification what are we going to deal
with the UTC problem system no I
understand that but what is that plan
for dealing with the glitches and UTC
relative to one of those other things
are seconds so that's in there that's in
the plans
so perhaps after after de terrain it
would be our next big thing for time
because we will need is for astrophysics
for a strong graphics right fair enough
well we'll be ready for when the yeah
when when when there's more going on in
space will be ready and we won't get it
wrong knowing that um you know what the
I mean I don't even know what people I
mean right now when when we say and I
don't know whether we have this data to
the I mean we say the landing time of
such-and-such a spacecraft right on Mars
for example I don't know whether we have
that to the hour a minute but clearly
that is in you know earth coordinate
system isn't it I guess so but these
things sometimes is stressed have an
indeterminacy like it's this famous
question of if there's Sun disappeared
right now we would take eight minutes to
notice it so when we compare our times
with the time of the Sun there is this
sure what I say look when it says you
know Apollo 11 touchdown on the lunar
surface at this particular second my
assumption is what we quote for that is
the second in the earth time system
yes yes but there is this assumption of
a mechanism to communicate both places
be a light ray and then you take the
midpoint I think than that why do you
need the middle I mean I'm just trying
to ask when we have data that says this
spacecraft landed on Mars at this time
right is it is it the time at which a
radio signal to earth recorded that the
spacecraft landed or is it the back
computed time in some Martian coordinate
system well I think it's it's a time
measured from Earth but removing what
you were saying before about right at a
time removing that the distance the time
the distance corresponding to the time
removing the time corresponding to a
distance tool to them okay so what
you're saying is if you know if you
watch the the live stream of you know
the spacecraft landing or whatever right
then you know everybody cheers in the
control room or whatever at time at you
know 15 minutes past midnight on the
earth but then that'd be time that we
would record for when the spacecraft
landed on Mars would be 11:55 p.m. the
previous day that's right right we know
that these stands for them so we divide
the speed of light that you know oh boy
this is gonna get confusing okay I mean
I don't know whether we have I don't
know we should ask Jeff whether whether
the data we have on on planetary probes
is that I mean we certainly that data
should exist to the minute points of a
second actually
of course then then the correction
depends on the actual distance to Mars
for example at the time when you know
you know it was on the opposite side of
the Sun it's gonna be a longer delay
well I can imagine that they date state
reports that were not really correct
these things are typically corrected but
but yeah we would have to check right I
mean in the same
think another mmm the same thing happens
for example with with elevations when
when elevations are reported on earth or
Mars or the moon etc sometimes they
subtract they do it sometimes they don't
and it's kind of messy
well weather it I mean that's like when
George Everest just decided that Mount
Everest was the tallest mountain in the
world right that is relative to the geo
ideas exactly yes yes but for example
the the did the elevations will report
because we have elevations for several
planets it turns out that in some of
them they obstructed the geoid
in others they didn't what do they do
with the other words they subscribe to a
spherical planet no they just measured
from from a sphere centered at the
center of mass but they don't measure
this year it and they're abstract so
what really I don't know so like Olympus
Mons for example its height is surely
not equal to a radius vector of Mars no
but what they do is that they agree on a
sphere and then they just abstract that
radius so they have a lame datum
basically experience a spherical datum
exactly in the future when they have
much better measurements of the moon and
they can measure I do it or perhaps they
can't really do it
they will subtract but I think the
problem of the moon is it's not
ellipsoidal is it it has this big lump
in it I think I don't know well it's
it's close to spherical and that's why
this very graphic summation is good but
still they do it whatever it is actually
they will call it the solenoid it's for
the moon it's a bumpy thing and and the
good elevations should be always
compared to them yeah that's kind of
worms because we're not doing that for
the earth right for the earth the clear
white is always an ellipsoid it's a
bumpy thing and we have data for it in
the innovation data you can say
undulation and you get there the
elevation with respect to the ellipsoid
of the year it okay but so why is it
then that is it obvious that Mount
Everest is the tallest mountain so to
speak based on that whole discussion
yes I mean the good elevations are those
with respect to the to the geoid a good
potential surface it's what you what you
feel when you are there locally that
it's a it's a horizontal it's there is
there
my future SEC I see so it's based on the
gravity vector which is perpendicular to
the vertical but when you're at the side
of a mountain right the it doesn't it
doesn't the mass of the mountain affect
what the vertical is Minh and precisely
that's why you have to very careful with
respect to which things you are
measuring because the right thing to
measure with respect to is the potential
surface and so for for these weird shape
things aren't spherical like you know
the moons of Mars or something that's
just a total kind of worms
absolutely okay so nobody gets to quote
the tallest mountain on Phobos or
something what is important here because
what I will respect the idea it you can
have water flowing from some distance to
in up from from a place to another place
that have the same elevation from with
respect to the ellipsoid but not with
respect to the Droid
because the gravitational potential is
different
okay fascinating all right well I think
we've we've nailed the stuff for these
date interval and so on designs and
sounds good right thanks guys and focus
on the live stream see you later bye